well guys
um today this is the sit down with pearl
welcome snico well it's nice to meet you
nice to meet you I am a fan of your work
I generally watch a lot of your podcast
for a while and I like what you're doing
thank you thank you I've I've been
watching you forever I love your
reaction videos I was telling you
earlier I just think you're so
entertaining and I feel like a lot of
the Flack you get is like I'm just like
he's an Entertainer he's trying to be
funny I don't know why people get so
caught up in like get their panties in a
bunch for no reason well it's facts
versus logic right now I know it's it's
logic versus emotion so
you have to seek true through funny
that's my motto I think anybody who's
funny or who's entertaining to
understand the truth because you can't
laugh at things that that are false
humor comes from your gut comes from
your stomach and so even right and left
right I don't even I'm not really that
politically Affiliated but I guess the
woke mob versus just people who are red
pill or who are truthful it all the
funny people are on this side and all
the people who are all emotional and
triggered they're always woke you know
the people who will believe in the truth
they don't get triggered at little
nonsense they they can see the Nuance in
things
no
that's why I was so mad when they when
they took you off of YouTube I literally
watched your streams all the time I
still do but but so what was that like
getting canceled it was funny it was the
day after I met with the tape Brothers
in Romania in um in Bucharest and we
flew to London on a private jet to he
was doing his Piers Morgan interview and
then that day I got the last email like
I got your final strike all my channels
deleted it's just all one unwanted time
sneako sneako sneako lit boom boom boom
all deleted and we saw that the walls
caving in like every when you get
canceled it's not like it comes out of
nowhere you can kind of tell there's
different signs they started age
restricting things they started deleting
certain videos and then the the types of
uh woke YouTubers who were saying
certain things that I should be banned
we saw it coming but for all that to
happen at once like that because it was
it was like I fell to my knees in
Walmart you know I had that type of
reaction but then I was being on Twitch
a week later for for no reason and I'm
still banned on switch people have been
able to get unbanned but I was I didn't
even say anything I was eating a salad
bam banovation done genuine I wasn't
even saying anything I was streaming for
a week uh to try to get the twitch
partnership or whatever so I wasn't even
have my my mic on mute and I still got
banned so they write me on Twitter Tick
Tock Elon Musk thank you for bringing me
back but the the cancellation hit me
pretty hard but I'm very very positive
because the past couple days on Rumble
it's been it's been absolutely
incredible it was the transition was a
little bit slower for me than most
people it wasn't the same exact amount
of viewers but now we're hitting a
stride and I'm really this Happy New
Year's Eve to anybody watching Happy New
Year's Eve 2023 I'm really looking
forward to the future of Rumble and uh
these alternative platforms
what
well do you think it was because of Tate
that you got banned like because you
visited him
I think that they start I I genuinely
think that there were they were watching
under a microscope there were different
signs they played me in the senate
committee played a clip of my stream and
said that we were inspiring
domestication because of the panel that
I had uh with Nick foyer I think that
was a big thing that that put me under
their their Spotlight they started to
look because that that's clearly a
person that they're afraid of that tests
the agenda and seeing that I wasn't
pushing back so you could talk to people
like that you could talk to canceled
people as long as you push back so maybe
you'll survive longer talking to cancel
people because you're you're a woman and
so it's more like comes from more of a
place of empathy but if I'm like nodding
my head with Nick they call a white
supremacist and ire and I'm like oh yeah
you're pretty funny like and I'm not
pushing back at all then they're like
this guy he's starting to platform him
we need to get rid of him no I genuinely
think that's like half the reason I
haven't been taken down is just because
I'm a girl like I just feel like they're
so much harder on goddess than they are
in girls on like Social Media stuff oh
for sure like I mean there was another
girl that was naked on Twitter having
sex on Twitch she got banned for seven
days she was getting [ __ ] on Twitch so
that they allow point this is the
priorities that's on Twitch you can be
in a hot tub half naked you can be
pushing Sim Behavior making men weaker
they want you to watch video games all
day they want you to listen to of woke
people they want to take away your brain
they just want you to sit there eating
this donating money to all these only
fan streamers watching people have sex
and then if I'm here like trying to wake
people up being energetic saying
something funny saying something that
test the agenda wiped I need you to Red
Pill me more
what do you want to know because it
really if this is how it starts for
everybody who goes down the red pill
pipeline uh you're here it's
relationship level which is good because
the fir that's the first step of the red
pill you realize that men are encouraged
to become Sims to Disney movie ideology
of Every Woman as a princess is a lie uh
you need to earn that
I'm sorry we're not all special damn it
but once you get there then you start to
figure out about like what's the reason
like why is feminism being pushed and
it's ultimately controlled
[Music]
it all starts from there because there's
a reason why we are all lied to about
relationships and it's because they want
ultimate control they want ultimate
power and just be logical why would the
powers that be care about us they want
more power that we're we're not uh they
don't give a [ __ ] about us why why
should they who okay so because this is
where I get confused all right so I get
the relationship stuff right like
feminism okay
who are the powers that be because okay
I'll tell you what happened to me a
couple years ago I was on a train and
some random dude just started talking to
me about the like Epstein's Island you
know and I thought this man was crazy
until a couple years later I was like
I'm like the Epstein stuff came out and
I was like is this man telling the truth
he was also telling me that all the
currency is going to go bad or something
but this was like when I was like 20. so
this is this was like six years ago this
was but I remember it because so much
stuff came true but I'm like who are the
powers that beat and like don't is it
like if terror is in the world is not
like bad for them like they don't want
to live in a bat I don't know
what do you think they think the
terrorism okay okay because I I always
hear that the powers that be are like
population control like that's what
they're trying to do but if there's
population control then they won't be
able to fill jobs in the future like
that's bad for societies like societies
crumble when there's not when there's a
declining population from what I
understand I'm not like an expert at
this stuff well they're trying to
automate everything they want to get rid
of those a lot of those jobs those
simple jobs like truck drivers you know
electric cars and McDonald's everything
is automated they want to take away a
lot of that population control is easier
because they know that having a family
is where we're happiest when we have a
we have kids and when we're
self-governing we don't listen to other
people they know that that's when when
we're independent we don't rely on other
people that's our happiest state so
that's why in the past few years they
took that away they told us to stay
inside you can't interact with other
people you can't go meet other people
it's you're a bad person if you go see
your family for Christmas they took away
what makes us what makes us happiest and
yeah of course he's right and we're
seeing the double standard right now
with the wolf mob Epstein's Island where
actual human traffickers they it's a
global sex trafficking ring that the
elites have you're asking what the
elites are it's just the people with the
most amount of money it's just like this
Mafia at the top a lot of people
speculate about who it is I genuinely
think it's just the people with the most
money I don't think it's any specific
race or religion they all they all make
deals as you know the people with the
most power these power hungry satanists
who don't believe in God and know that
they can manipulate and do the rituals
to to get rid of any of their empathy if
they if they believe in negative
behavior if they know that they can go
against God and play as God then they'll
have ultimate control and they won't
care about how much they do to us
so but you see the double standard right
now that right now Tristan said an
agitator getting accused of human
trafficking which is all [ __ ] I know
that I was in their house there's no no
women are there in cages but look at the
woke people they don't care about the
Black Book of the Epstein list they
don't give a [ __ ] about actual if they
cared about human trafficking they would
say hey Please Release the list of
people that went to Epstein's Island
they don't care well and it's guilty
that's I was going to ask you about that
it's guilty until proven innocent with
him with men yeah with or especially if
they're like more conservative men like
with Andrew it's like they don't even
wait till the facts come out it's like
they just assume he's guilty and do you
see how many there are like how many
remember this when when the tastes out
when their name is clear just remember
this like clip this when it comes out
that they're innocent all the
influencers who are saying the pizza box
docks to he docks himself with the pizza
box Greta thundberg W you [ __ ] idiots
you don't think some of the most famous
people in the world in Europe who flew
on a private jet into Romania driving
expensive Bugattis to their mansion
that's on Google Maps you think the
government wasn't aware of their
location you genuinely think a pizza box
is what got them arrested and all of
them said that preach I know you talked
to him
who else were all these people who
pushed the moodahar from ordinary gamers
they were all speaking about this pizza
box and they're all well older than us
they're in their mid-30s who just
believe one tweet they have no
analytical skills and they they sit
online all day playing video games
they're supposed to be nerds the Nerds
anybody who believe in that pizza box
[ __ ] you have no right to speak about
this at all just stay play video games
stop trying to get into the truth it was
crazy
that dude he said that he's like oh I
saw it was a pizza box bro has like kids
and is married and really believe that a
pizza box is what got him arrested
uh and these are the influencers that
have all these platforms and have all
these subscribers and that people pay
attention to and people like me get
banned
[Music]
I think if you if you analyze it
properly I I don't see uh I'm not very
optimistic about the future of the West
um with everything that we believe in
woke is in a religion uh people don't
people think completely emotionally that
they're they're not gonna want to watch
your debate or I want to listen to them
talk there is not a lot of Hope for
these people so I think the best thing
to do and I would advise anybody who who
sees the truth is to make as much money
as possible get strong have multiple
passports and not be able to be
controlled by any government and and get
ready to to leave but there's there's
certain people that that want to save
America but it's
I I have a hard time being optimistic
about it but what do you think is going
to happen
what's going to happen in the Deep State
I want to be red pilled more what's
going to happen to you well they want a
globalist agenda that they want to have
the world be controlled by one powerful
government that has all the money they
want us to be eating bugs they don't
want us to be patriotic about it and
they want that's what the world at
economic forum is that's what Klaus
Schwab wants uh China wants to take over
they just want a specific group of
people to control everybody
okay I need you to so you're saying
names I don't know these are like super
rich people have been is the head of the
world economic Forum okay and they they
shake hands with people like George
George Soros and that he's bad I've
heard his name he's bad yes yeah I mean
these Ultra billionaires that's all they
want the same people with Bill Gates
they're all part of this Elite group and
if you look what happened in uh what's
happening in the Netherlands right now
they're closing up all the Farms they
don't they don't even want you to grow
your own food so they can control your
food supply it's the same reason they're
pushing veganism out on everybody
because they know that like eating uh
animals like it makes you a stronger
person they're pushing impossible
Burgers they want you to eat bugs they
want you to genetically modified food
they want to control everything about us
they're shutting down farms in the
Netherlands the world economic Forum has
taken over that country really really
yeah so so what do you think will happen
to America then
you think they'll take over like they'll
do the same thing to take over the farm
I think you could look at what's
happening in China and analyze that and
think that it's probably going to happen
here next because covet happened there
first the vaccine passports the
lockdowns the quarantine that happened
in China and then it then happened in
America right now if you look at like
covet is still completely all over China
like we're like oh it's over it's not
over in China you when you drive on the
highway you need to scan a QR code to
pass they have um giant tents and they
have just look up Shanghai on Twitter
you can see all these videos you can't
you have to walk on the street in a
certain direction or else you get
arrested they'll like just bring you in
it's genuinely Black Mirror stuff so if
if we elect another Democrat if we elect
somebody else like Joe Biden
then it's very possible that the same
thing is happening in China like a
totalitarian government who just wants
us controlled is the future would you
ever move
D because some people just that are
super red pale they'll just flee I'm out
well I don't have enough money I I
recently I just became a millionaire
this year I started this year broke
um you were telling me that you've
started watching for a long time I was
I've been doing YouTube for a long time
but this year I started with the million
YouTube subscribers and I finished it
with a million dollars with no YouTube
channel so no it's a it's a pretty
interesting flip a million subscribers
and not a million dollars at a flip I
think like once I get to 5m or or 10
million net worth and I am generating
enough Revenue uh to that point that
I'll get out of here but I'm not
financially ready yet I'm in the best
place in America this is just
objectively the best place in America
you would considering moving here look
outside Brickell I think is the best
Miami is like is the Dubai it's like a
Utopia and a collapsing Society of
America so actually I have questions
about Miami so I was thinking
I'm not a big like I don't really drink
so I'm like can I can you like Miami and
not be that into like the clubs and
stuff yeah of course there's great
restaurants great weather nice people
the food is it's the best food ever my
second concern okay I'm a ginger all
right you need sunscreen yeah but it's
so I heard it's like ungodly hot in the
Summers like it's like death like deadly
it's it's doable it's doable yeah you're
in London you're used to rain all the
time I think you could adjust I need to
get out of London I hate London yeah
London is is fun I I liked it the past
three years I would go every summer but
uh Andrew and Tristan they hate it they
think it's like you have to hide your
watch when you go outside I haven't had
that experience personally I've even
went to the hoods of the Peckham I've
been to Brick Center but all these
places it was fine for me I think it's a
little bit exaggerated but maybe my
experience is not the same but I I like
the people I live in the hood low-key
yeah what what uh what area we can cut
it
okay it's not the best I used to live
America you lived before that it was
like there was a body found down the
street okay yeah it says in the best
area but I wanted like a bigger place
and back then the channel wasn't doing
as well so I was like like it was doing
good but like now I probably would have
lived somewhere else but I don't know
then it was more of like a risk to sign
a lease that long you know oh you're
still in the lease yeah but
um
yeah but I'm gonna because I'm placed on
my Pro volleyball now like that's why
I'm there so once my season ends I'm
coming back
where's your Utopia where do you want to
move I don't know do you agree with what
I'm talking about that the West is
collapsing and that it's
um
yeah I mean that sounds like
that sounds right that sounds so dumb
like I don't I'm like it doesn't seem to
be getting better no everyone gets like
crazier every five years and I think we
should look at what happened in the past
two years how quickly everybody jumps on
to exactly what they're supposed to
leave and then move on all the people
that shamed you for not wanting to get
an injection or shamed you for seeing
your family or all the going outside
during the quarantine all these people
who said you were a terrible person
there were people on Twitter and like
people post screenshots all the time
saying these people shouldn't have
rights if you didn't get an injection
like these people should not be able to
speak these people should not be allowed
to leave your house if you didn't get
this and they're just still here
tweeting moving on with their life that
people are genuinely really brainwashing
They Don't Really Care uh people because
of social media we just move on to the
next thing most people are completely
controlled so if we see that most people
are like this I think I think when the
next one happens my prediction is the
next pandemic is going to be about
climate change I think it's going to be
limiting how much carbon you can emit so
they're going to say that you can't
drive a certain amount hours you can
only leave at this amount of time you've
been using the internet too much the
same thing you can't use an air
conditioning system in the UK right like
because the sun's too hot it's just it's
all nonsense and this is the next
pandemic
[Music]
so what made you not be brain were you
ever bran you had to of course I I was
stuck in The Matrix for I grew up in The
Matrix I grew up in um I was born in New
York City and I grew up in a lot of New
Haven Connecticut my parents are my
family like my whole environment
everybody around me was stuck into that
system I dropped I was in college and I
think like I've always was red pill
aware but I think everyone is red pillow
where at some point and then we just
give up and then we choose to be a slave
to the system
and when I was in college I knew I
didn't want to be there when I was in
school you know that when you're in
school they're training you to be part
of the nine to five so that you can ask
to go to the bathroom so you are trained
to take lunch at a certain time it's
training you for the nine to five
routine and then as soon as you leave
you become a debt slave so then now you
need to work and become part of the
workforce to pay off your debt and you
take out the system of taking out loan
and I was in college and I realized I
didn't want to do this I don't want to
be an intern
um at some TV studio for like NBC's die
like I want it to be
um I wanted to be saying things that
were impactful I I like media and I they
were telling me that you need to be an
intern for three years at ABC Studios in
order to get into that oh you just need
to do the do the time like why do I need
to do this time you know I want to be
self-governing I don't want to have to
listen to anybody so that they train you
to be a slave and I think we're all
aware of that but most of us it takes it
takes a level of courage and it takes
um take it's it's scary to take that
first step like when I dropped out of
school you know I didn't have a backup
plan I was making like two three
thousand a month and I said [ __ ] it like
I just don't want to do this and I've
made mistakes I've been to a part of
degeneracy I have been an Atheist before
I have fallen into the woke mob many
times it's been documented I've been on
YouTube for a long time but I I'm just
like everybody else watching like I
think inherently we all want to make it
out did you do you feel like YouTube got
you out of it like watching YouTube
content
YouTube
got me in and out at the same time
because a lot of it pulls you in most of
what's on social media will just pull
you in more and then all the people that
are trying to pull you out they end up
banned or they end up censored they end
up being called racist misogynisticated
accused of something they didn't do they
try to silence those people but the
people that are pushing the degeneracy
the atheistic people the people who want
you to play video games all day wants
you to stay inside pushing the woke
agenda saying that a man can become a
woman they get on the trending page like
why is it that I'm Ben on YouTube but
Shane Dawson someone like that a known
pedophile is number one on trending I
don't know I don't know who that is it's
one of the OG YouTubers like and
everybody knows what he's done but they
don't ban those people but someone like
me I'm banned because of misinformation
there's a very clear bias well and we
should be allowed to be wrong like
that's what I'm saying like they'll say
misinformation like you should be
allowed to have a stream and say
something wrong and correctly there's so
much misinformation and you can and
that's what irritates me sometimes about
the red pill is like they're like if you
say anything wrong like but it's like
it's like
I just feel like the chat and like
people are so quick to correct you and
like especially being in the positions
we are like like people are so quick for
you to get something wrong and like try
to correct you so it's like even if
something happens like you can correct
it later like we should be allowed it's
freedom of speech
yeah that's why I praise Elon for doing
that but exactly that they want you to
have one specific opinion and that's the
the position you put yourself in as a
content creator you put yourself at you
know in front of a lot of people you're
going to get scrutinized all the time
for having the wrong opinion which is
good to have discussion to have back and
forth you have somebody who never is
going to engage in a debate or have it
back for someone like Greta thumbberg
and she's the the voice of climate
change before she's Jesus of the woke
movement and she knows better than to
have a debate why do they have a 13 year
old
I'm so stupid the left is how does the
13 year old know anything about the
planet they don't think her her parents
that is child abuse oh she's 19. I mean
now but when she started she was like 13
14 it was a couple years ago yeah when
they had the I shouldn't be here you
know what I'm talking about yeah I
shouldn't be it was like yes you're so
emotional it's just literally the human
embodiment of emotions over logic like
she knows nothing about science why does
she know more about the sun being hot
and you know what a good example of how
how many double standards there are with
the woke movement
everyone just said that the giant owned
that she said was uh Andrew Tate small
oh way clap it up but you know it's you
get in trouble for calling right body
shamer body shamer as soon as the face
of the woke movement says small body
shaming and everybody claps good job for
body shaming a man that's the double
standard you couldn't they think of it
as punching up but it's there's no
consistency with the morality no I do
love
[Music]
I lost a childhood friend like 20 years
over the fat comments 20 years and
that's the crazy thing is like they'll
literally like the when they're
brainwashed it's like literally people
that have loved you and like have been
with you your whole life will just stop
being friends with you or stop talking
to you that's happened to me yeah yeah I
was gonna ask you if that's happened to
you too yeah I mean I've been I've been
talking about it like uh I said you
asked me if I was ever part of the
Matrix I consider like my family is
still learning a lot of stuff and people
have like this really strong emotional
reaction to stuff like this that they
don't know how to even speak to people
they they can't even speak about the
vaccine or if you voted I voted for
Trump and like if I told people that
they would like call me racist they
would have called me a trump supporter
that was the word for Nazi back then
that so I kept that secret I didn't tell
a lot of people when people did find out
they would look at me like this like I
didn't this is the first Christmas I
didn't go home because of my association
with yay because yay was talking about
um they called him anti-semitic they
lied about him and so my association
with the people that you want to have on
a panel like Nick Fuentes and yay that
that pushed me away they're like I don't
we don't want you to talk about this
wait so like your mom my family just
like my whole family really your whole
family all vaccinated all Biden voters
all Ukraine you know I stop it can you
red pill some of them yeah I tried to
I've tried to my my brother is uh more
susceptible but like eventually when you
when you get that far into it it's um
that's just the way it is and I still
love them of course and I'm sure they
still love me but the reason is like
they just wouldn't be able to handle a
conversation at the dinner table because
you know what people don't know how to
have discourse they don't know how to
disagree healthily they get so
emotionally involved and they want to
live in their delusion they want to be
like the factor who's saying I'm perfect
the way I am so I mean I don't hold any
animosity of course is going to get
better in the future but it's just
that's how plugged in so many people are
how do you stay so positive like you've
had every bad thing happen to you so
your family doesn't talk to you yeah you
want to be racist I've lost all my
platforms YouTube froze 200 000 of my
dollars
um you know a lot of people on the
internet they I get attacked all you
know there's there's a lot no of course
how do I say positive I just I trust in
the process I believe in God I've been
going back to church
um I have a strong network of friends I
have a good Community around me my I've
been saying in my chat that's why my
real machine been doing so well like my
chat's my family like that's what I look
forward to every single night it's New
Year's Eve and I'm just excited to get
on stream see all the same like
usernames that I see I talk to them all
the time like I'll be streaming for like
and that's what I want to do in 2023 I'm
streaming every single day at uh 8 PM
Eastern and on rumble.com Nico that
that's my that's the family right now
that that's that's who I uh spend the
most time with so I I have I just have a
positive mindset because that's the only
thing you can do even when uh Andrew and
Tristan got arrested like of course they
predicted it they told me it was going
to happen and I know it's all a lie like
I'll put my reputation on the line to
say that they're innocent
um of course there's a lot of things
they beat you down they they they want
you to fall apart because they want you
to stay plugged in but the only thing
you could do is trust in God become
stronger richer and Trust the process
now I absolutely don't believe like he
was so nice on the interview everybody
who's met him says that yeah everybody
who hates him hasn't met him and they
just see Clips on Tick Tock they believe
in the brainwashing every single person
I have not met one person who said that
Andrew Richardson Tate is once they
shake his hand yeah like um we were
supposed to go to Dubai for that panel
actually and my passport expires within
six months so I can't get in the country
and he ended up like flying to us so we
could do it and so I was like that was
really nice yeah yeah and I was like
that was really nice of him to do that
so I don't know I mean there all that
stuff came out about him I just don't
believe it he said that it was going to
happen yeah no it's a lie they don't
have anything do you get tired
okay I don't you go on fresh and fit a
lot right yeah I was on last night I'm
so tired of these
like respectfully I've been doing the
show for like a year now
like I sound like a man now I'm sick of
these hoes not like respectfully I know
like people be like
stop calling the girls hot like but they
are they are and they even they use that
word to their advantage they'd be like
I'm a hoe and then it's you you're like
okay hoe what do you mean like they'll
be like let me I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] walk it's
like
I have never understood men more than
doing this show it's like the men will
show up on time the women are flaky God
only knows if they'll show up to the
podcast I have to get double the amount
of women just to get the panel and and
it's like I and I I like to say I don't
think I'm better than I'm still a girl
I'm not special okay I'm not a unicorn
but it's like a lot of times
they make everything about them it's
like we'll be talking about a general
conversation and it's always about that
and it's like women are the main
character in a movie in their head
Disney's done that every girl is a
prince is a Disney princess in her own
head you saw it I was pointing it out in
your debate you're trying to talk about
feminism and every single time a woman
speaks she's like as a black Trans queer
what the what are you talking about the
conversation was about the wage Gap what
does this have to do with being black
like they just every single time they
need to victimize themselves because
they need to feel special every time
they speak I'm confused how are you Red
Pill like what what was your journey
into this [ __ ] weird space
um well I've always been more
conservative I'd say that they
brainwashed me for like maybe a year or
two in college just a little bit I was
like probably yeah oh God no no I was
never I was never that crazy I was just
more like I was always still more
conservative but I would say maybe on a
couple social issues they kind of got me
like BLM type stuff I kind of felt bad
for being white for a minute
yeah I was like I hate guilty weapons
that's what racist against is guilty
yeah well I didn't do in the wild [ __ ]
that they're doing but it was like um
like and privileged and I grew up in the
most privileged life ever like I grew up
in a 10 bedroom house with nine siblings
like we traveled the world I'm like you
can't get more privileged than me so I
just felt really bad and I was like oh
[ __ ] like did I contribute to like the
problems are you contributing to white
supremacy like yeah you're part of the
problem maybe like a year system of
Oppression my dad but then my dad he's
so logical that he would and I was like
maybe we should have benefits and [ __ ]
you know because I was like well I up
like this like you did it but my dad
um I just remember this is kind of the
red pill moment but this wasn't about
relationships this was like other stuff
but like I feel like red pill kind of
starts with like conservative policies
too at least it did for me and he was
just explaining to me you can't have
free [ __ ] like you have to have he was
like one dollar and two dollars out you
can only have so many of those personal
responsibilities yeah and that's like he
would just sit me down and explain stuff
to me and I'd be like oh
like you can't the the relationships was
just reacting to videos like Kevin
Samuels kind of read yeah I could see
that a lot a lot of the need to be right
um a lot of his his phrases I hear on
your podcast yeah like um what do you
talk about when he RP Kevin said yeah I
know he was great it's so sad he was
gone too soon
um but he I'm trying to remember oh oh
that he triggered me the first time I
was triggered because they were like you
need to see Kevin Samuels I used to do
rap reactions so it's like why does girl
on earth reacts to like push iced tea or
like something like that
so then then I did um whitest girl on
earth reacts to Kevin Samuels and it was
the high value men cheat one and my
dad's a hot like he's a high value man
so I called him I'm like Dad where are
your [ __ ] like why don't you opposed
and he's like what you know yeah um but
that kind of he really called your dad
and said that yeah no I'm I'm really I
talked to my dad like every other day
okay it's not he kind of gets annoyed he
says like I'm calling too much make some
friends but
um yeah but I realized like they're more
talking about it on like in the state of
the world so at first I was like
triggered because I grew up around rich
people and none of them really cheated
like that just wasn't common and I know
the everyone read pill be like they do
and you just don't know it but like I
grew up more around like the nerdy guys
I don't know they just weren't like they
might be I don't know No One Believes me
but I really don't think my dad's ever
cheated and
so but what I realized is they're just
saying like most guys if they have a bus
full of models waiting for them at the
door are probably gonna do it at some
point and you can see that like what
percent of NBA players are faithful no
no no and I was like you know even my
dad as much as I love him if he had
girls waiting for him every day at home
it would probably be hard for him too so
yeah I was triggered by some stuff at
first it's it's uh interesting that it
was your your father in conservatism uh
because I think the first thing that
really red pilled me was when Trump ran
for president in 2015 and everybody was
calling him racist my motto was always
just following the funny uh because I
always really like standard comedy from
a young age I like George Carlin Louis
CK Dave Chappelle those people and woke
people just aren't funny they aren't
capable of it and Trump was like just
seeing him get on stage
low energy
small like just all the jokes and the
memes they just didn't care he's like
they're coming
and I I always resonate I believe in
funny people because I don't think you
can [ __ ] around funny you know if
you look at Kamala Harris if you look at
Joe Biden like Pamela Harris would be
like uh at Thanksgiving dinner I just
put gravy on the turkey
like it's just creepy like when they try
to be if they're like an alien so but if
you're funny then I know you're a real
person so it was Trump and just not
believing in the establishment tired of
the robots and then uh you go fully down
here and you can see now what's
happening to Trump they raided his house
in Mar-A-Lago uh the same thing that's
happening at Tate right now and people
don't see the pattern they did the same
thing with Julian Assange everybody
who's trying to test the powers that be
they will they will falsely accuse them
of nonsense and they're so robotic too
it's like they're robots they are yeah
no Bots NPCs you got to add that to your
vocabulary and they they it really
nobody wants to think that they're a bot
so it's really triggering to them I'll
say that every time every time a liberal
does something to be bought but oh
Ukraine bot and they're like what they
don't know how to come back from that
it's a great and it's a great word I
just don't like and the other reason I
feel like I'm red pills I just really
hate people feeling sorry for themselves
I've just always been a hard worker like
probably to a fault like I've just
always tried hard at like things that I
do whether it's like volleyball or music
or like whatever it is and I just
I feel like you can accomplish anything
in life and I just don't like it when
girls are like oh boo hoo poor me I'm a
woman blah blah blah it's just like I'm
a woman I could do it I like I know
people in way worse situations than you
that can do it and it's like I really
believe you can do anything if you can
and that's a powerful mindset to have
it's the belief and uh another reason
was like they diagnosed with ADHD when I
was a little kid and that that's a
disability that's a mental disability so
if I believe that I'm disabled then I'm
going to have a worse life if I believe
I'm depressed I'm going to be depressed
they tried to give me the that too they
tried to drug me they tried to drug me
they did for a while when I was I was
like 12 they gave me these pills and a
lot of people fall into this because
they don't they don't want it it goes
they don't want to take any
accountability for their decisions but
it goes bigger than just women it's
being black it's being POC it's being
queer it's being a minority it's being
I'm uh able it's any of these words
people don't want to take responsibility
for the life but I'm telling you
everybody here everybody has some
disadvantage everybody can label
themselves as a minority a minority in
any way but that will hold you back in
life more than anything it's a belief
it's a mindset if you can get rid of
that what's possible is incredible and
I'm telling you somebody this year I
started this year broke I'm a
millionaire at the end of it even though
I sacrifice all my platforms you see
where I'm at now I am telling you it's
possible
I want to Ginger minority I don't know
why you are a minority technically yeah
yeah I know I just don't understand why
we don't get like minority privileges as
a ginger
I just feel like we're like
discriminated against you have no soul
yeah but I don't know I just I really
hate people that are victims like I just
cannot stand it like I just feel like
we're actually feel good yeah and I just
like work hard like you can you can
literally do anything and that's what I
got to see my dad growing up like he he
started broke on the south side of
Chicago and he built a business for
software that like employed over 250
people so it's like
I just don't I can't see it well it's
hard to work hard and the reason people
pick the victim mindset is because of
all the distractions if people are on
Tick Tock all day if they're invested in
different things like BLM and they're
emotional about Ukraine stuff that has
nothing to do with their life then
they're being drained constantly if
they're like jerking off on Twitch and
they're donating money to girls that
don't care about them and they're
invested and like these parasocial
relationships so they're constantly on
dating apps if they're constantly on
Instagram stories comparing themselves
to other people they are their Energy's
being drained and so that energy that
you can put into something that's going
to make you better and working hard they
don't have it anymore because everything
else The Matrix is trying to drain you
of your energy but you need to conserve
it do you consider yourself a red pill
content creators yeah what do you think
of women in the red pill I've heard
we're like problems
um I I like what you talk about I think
that's uh I think it's it's very
necessary to have a voice like you in
this space
um I'll be on like some like Myron will
say that um women should not be in this
space because they can't relate to male
problems but the red pills is much
bigger than just relationships as we've
discussed it's not just about men and
women it's it's much it goes about
because goes deeper it goes into them
trying to control your every single move
so I I think that you do have a valid
place in in this space that's why I'm
here and I respect what you do cool I've
been trying to get you on forever yeah
yeah I was like that sounds like I could
do anything I got sneako on today
if you work hard yeah that's what I'm
saying like I don't know hold on
um oh what do you think about how Elon
Musk has been doing as the CEO of
Twitter the Liberals will say that he's
doing a bad job but of course he's going
to sacrifice his reputation and then now
they're going to his stocks are going to
plummet because a lot of the Liberals
like to have control in these places
there's uh big investment firms like
BlackRock and they have a woke score for
if they want to invest in a company
right so if Target wait I'm sorry okay
you got it you gotta slow it down I'll
explain this so there's big investment
firms like like BlackRock they have
trillions of dollars and then they can
decide they have money in one of the
some of the biggest corporations in the
world so if they want to invest in
Target for example say that Target wants
to make a bunch of new new locations
they will decide if they're worthy of
investing if their woke score is high so
Target will do that by putting gay pride
flags on the front by doing a bunch of
woke stuff
oh so that's why all the companies are
so that's why all the companies they
keep saying these bottles yeah that's
why they put because it's a sign to
other companies look how woke we are
because they know that woke is good it's
not because they care about it it's
because it keeps everybody controlled
correct Elon Musk his woke score since
buying Twitter and since freeing people
like me freeing Cobra Tate and a lot of
the people bringing back free speech on
Twitter his woke score went completely
down as a result Tesla stock plummets
everything like that the liberal was
like uh what an idiot what an [ __ ] he
lost his money Elon Musk is dumb so he
sacrifices reputation for free speech I
love what he did and history will favor
him well but right now you're going to
see outrage you're going to see people
laughing at him but what he's doing is
good for the future of humanity what do
you think because he banned Kanye did
you agree with that or disagree
I disagree with that yay should be able
to go on Twitter I I I am a free speech
absolutist we should have Alex Jones
should be free of course he almost could
have done a lot more Alex Jones yay
um and even what he did like what did
gay do he tweeted
um the Jewish star with the swastika
that's saying that we should love
everybody like I understood what he was
saying like like no no like when he did
that interview on Alex Jones I watched
the whole thing I didn't I didn't think
it was racist I don't know who would he
be racist to no like I understood what
he was saying like I understood how they
clipped it you know yeah when you take
it out of context you don't get it he
was saying love ever like love everybody
that's what Jesus would do that's what
God wants us to do to love everybody he
finally broke that last Matrix damn I
was I was in the camp I was in Easy
studio in L.A working on the campaign
when that happened like and I was
watching it and I'm like [ __ ] when I
heard the clip there's a lot of things
that I love about him
just like thinking part of the campaign
but he really I think it was good that
he said that that was the last thing
that the woke people always worse than
Hitler was Trump's Hitler Hitler Hitler
Hitler Hitler fine I love Hitler boom
now what do they have he broke that last
wall and I commended for saying that do
you think America do you think
is still running for president
of course yeah yay 24. yeah
I actually think he might win I've been
saying this because he's so entertaining
and I feel like so many people like him
he's a likable guy I think that the new
politicians will be entertainers they
already are trying yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying comedian I think that the
left is going to get the Rock
and I think they're just going to get
entertainers and that's going to be the
new politicians Dwayne Johnson yeah I
think like gone are the days like in 50
years gone are the days of like the the
boring ass politicians like I think it
will be entertaining you have to you
have to utilize uh because that's how
you get people to come out nobody would
go to a Joe Biden rally like if any woke
person tries to have a sellout Stadium
No One's Gonna show up no one wants to
go like what are the what's the
atmosphere at a Joe Biden rally gonna be
like what are they gonna what's their
slogan what's their ideology no one has
there's no energy but Trump he can go to
Stadium right now like instead be like
I'm gonna be at the FTX arena in Miami
everyone would show up we'd be doing
chants we're like America like
everyone's happy I went to a lot of
trump rallies in 2016. that [ __ ] was so
much fun like a feminist came in with a
sign like Trump's better was like lock
her up lock her up and then the police
escorted her out and was like yeah
foreign
agree with all this stuff it was just
like the energy was was very it was very
apparent and it's not it's not the same
for for people on the left so would you
still go to a trump rally now oh hell
yeah oh yeah great content yeah I would
actually go to a Joe Biden rally too
um it's just great content it's just you
can Farm like be the math squares just
go up and ask them three questions like
what's some rights that women have that
men don't have or what's the rights that
women don't have the men have and they
they won't know they won't say anything
it's just easy content trigger them yeah
I love triggering the lips it's so much
fun it's so much fun because they're
just like kids yeah they're like
children and when Kevin Samuels had a
stream called our modern women children
and after doing the show for a year I
think yes I think women like and I know
I am a woman I'm not special but we are
kids basically like that's how we think
because we ride on emotion like
literally you think so what do you think
about people calling you a pick me oh oh
my gosh at first I didn't know what a
pick me was so I was like what the hell
is a pick me but okay I think it
basically means and I oh my gosh even
the men do this to me too they'll be
like they'll call me Derek Jax whatever
the frick that guy's name is
um like it's basically meaning Derek
Jackson the guy that you don't know okay
well
it's basically saying that I don't
believe what I say and I just say it to
get picked but I don't know I'm just not
that filtered like I can't really prove
to someone that I believe what I say
like I guess with pekinges you don't
believe what you said yeah I think it
just means a girl that wants to be
picked well I mean I do want to get
married so that's a stupid insult anyway
but I feel like they're saying like
you're saying this stuff so the guys
will pick you so you don't believe what
you say you're just saying it because
you're a pick me that's how I took it
you don't think so I thought pikmi is
just any girl that wants to be picked
because girls now they want to be girl
boss CEOs feminist empowerment they're
like I can do I don't need a man and so
a girl that wants a relationship is a
pygmy because she's like hey look I'm
presenting myself as a woman and they
they've made that they've demonized that
oh my gosh and this is the thing about
feminists they don't want these problems
this is the thing like like owning a
business or whatever like there's [ __ ]
that I hate and stresses me out so much
and I have a plan to like Outsource it
to like men but I'm like you you
literally don't want to be in control of
people like I'm telling you like the
girls that like talk about this I'm like
you don't want it you know what I mean
it's it's too much work and especially
if you come from a place of emotion it
and then you have that problem too when
you moderate debates it's difficult
because people just inherently don't
want to listen to women like women just
inherently
are not capable leaders yeah and every
female coach or boss I've had I really
haven't liked at all no you call them a
[ __ ] as soon as they turn away yeah
yeah
I don't know it's like
yeah
the let me see what other ones am I in
what is your advice to men who struggle
with having success with women
I wouldn't be think about it a lot of
guys read a lot of stuff online I I went
down that rabbit hole when I was like 16
17 so I think I went through that early
um or maybe 50 yeah 15 16 17. I was
reading a lot of this book reading uh
red pill forms on the internet I read
the game by Neil Strauss I don't know if
you've read that I've read that yeah
that was a good one but I wouldn't think
about it I would just try to constantly
improve yourself every day and I would
work on yourself and your business and I
think the women will will follow if you
follow your masculine imperative uh but
a lot of guys they get into this Rabbit
Hole of self-improvement and all it
really is is going to the gym or it'll
just be in the gym every day but you're
not improving your social skills you're
not improving your business you have no
you're not interested you have no
Hobbies you have nothing to talk about
you have no life experience so if you
improve every single aspect of your life
and as a person the women will just
arrive
okay I have a question
about and I'm if you don't talk about
this yeah okay
can you tell me about the swinger party
yeah how did like I just talked about on
many podcasts so
I have always been a cheater like I've
always inherently wanted to cheat and
I've had several relationships where
it's just like and I this is part of the
reason I red pilled me so I was in uh
different relationships and I just I
constantly wanted to to sleep around but
I felt shamed into and but I'm like me
wanting to cheat has nothing to do with
my girlfriend
it has nothing to do with it and so they
make you seem like a bad person and I
had a couple relationships uh fail
because of that because of cheating and
stuff like that and then in a previous
relationship I I was
what wasn't cheating I would say like we
would
you did the open I did the open thing so
I'm sleeping around it would make her
really emotional to make her really
upset and it would seem unfair so I
thought okay to balance it out let's go
like let's go to a swinger party and
like swap with a couple and we can make
a fair and oh so that was the only time
you did that yeah we went to uh oh I
totally thought it was like a whole open
relationship so you just brought her to
the swing yeah I bought a swinger party
and then I didn't I would try to swap
with a couple it's just like being
around other men it's just not for me I
don't recommend it for anybody and
that's a testament to the fact that men
can sleep around and not get their
emotions involved but women do get their
emotion involved and it's different like
sleeping around as a man is not the same
as sleeping around as a woman so are you
still with that girl because I thought
someone said that you were I have uh
several oh okay but she's one of them
um yeah well yeah if you don't want it
then we can cut it I don't know you need
to cut anything yeah I'm a transfer
person I stream every day there's
nothing I have the side but okay
um has that what has it been like
managing that like different girlfriends
is that been hard or has it been easy
it's been they come and go they come and
go I I've been focused on myself for the
most part you know I don't really
I don't I wouldn't call them
like full-time relationships I've been
I've been so I've been streaming so much
that you know I'm not spending as much
time with them and like doing like
cuddling up watching Netflix and like
doing boyfriend girlfriend [ __ ] to smoke
I'll see you like twice a week something
like that so that they might be they
might see me as the boyfriend but I
don't really see them as as the girl I
think that's the best way to manage it
you know just don't get too emotionally
invested and be the man that they want
but managing that has been tough I I
understand why you asked that question
because uh people use that to discredit
a lot of what I talk about in
relationships I the people found out
about because I said it on a podcast
because I tried it and I just I didn't
like it and I I'm an honest person I
think a lot of people aren't open about
mistakes that they've made so I wanted
to talk about it it was it's just funny
to talk about you know like imagine
imagine putting yourself in a situation
like realizing like oh [ __ ] I don't want
to be here you know and every single
streamer every single person who
dislikes me everybody on the woke has
made fun of me for that and
there was this dude a moist critical
Penguins who's constantly saying like
I'm a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] and bro the guy's
like five six he plays video games all
day and he's been oh he's such a losers
he was on a stream calling me this one
nerds I'm like bro if I'm a like pull up
and just like say that to my face like
if you would say that to my face then I
guess he's like no watch these twitch
clips and I'm like I'll watch the twitch
Clips if you show it next to me on your
phone you're in Florida I'll pull up
right now I'm tired of your head pieces
I'm not on Twitch I'm not on YouTube if
you're more manly than me then tell me
that to my face and they won't they they
can't do it they use this to to
discredit what I talk about no and
that's the thing like it's crazy I was
telling you earlier like the ones that
say they hate you and they see you in
person they act like your best friend
yeah it's so weird you bring them on
your podcast all the time all the time
if like the one girl was saying oh
you're racist you're sexist swear to God
after the podcast she had a whole story
saying how much she likes me now it's
like that's the this is the nature of
the internet this is it's changed any
actual human interaction and and also
it's uh it's made it's it's given a
platform for for negativity and hate
like it's told people it's good to
you're like if I make a video saying I
like pearly things nobody's gonna watch
it if I say the truth about pearly
things exposed A million hits people
like drama that's why everybody watches
murder documentaries that's why they all
watch these shows and they YouTube now
used to be a place of creativity but if
you look at like what they say about me
now there's a new documentary
legitimately a documentary about me
every single day like investigating into
the mind of snico they like to like ooh
they like to negativity is is uh has run
wild on Netflix on all these platforms
have you considered making a documentary
like yourself
I come from a filmmaking background I
went to film school and I've made uh
when I was on YouTube before I started
streaming for like eight nine years
that's what I was known for was like
documentary like movie style
um videos and pretty artistic I I've
made documentary type videos this video
called how to view women and that I have
it's a documentary I would consider it's
on it's on my Rumble page but yet that's
where I want to graduate to I'm still
young and I want to utilize the
streaming thing and make enough money to
where I could start uh sourcing and make
my own documentary because I know that
any movie industry company at like
Warner Brothers I'm not going to ever
get a deal probably like I've dug myself
a hole for what I talk about and giant
networks consider me a wrist so the only
solution for me to want to direct movies
to make enough money where I become the
production company I thought your old
interviews like I know those videos I
thought they were beautiful like I feel
like there's certain content that I look
at it as like it's literally beautiful
and like that's how I felt about like
the street interviews you used to do
because sometimes I feel like there's a
piece of content that like kind of shows
what's going on in society and it's like
these people are having a conversation
on screen but it like shows what's going
on like the current psyche of the world
yeah and that's how I like try to do on
the channel like when I put Brittany
Renner and Andrew Tate together that was
a moment yeah yeah a conversation that
was that day because that's what's
happening is like there's a bunch of
girls waking up around 30 with a kid
from maybe it's not an NBA player but
it's a town rapper or whoever it is and
it's like they can't get the men that
they want anymore which like Andrew Tate
was supposed to like simply symbolize
you see what so yeah I don't know I used
to love those videos I thought they were
great yeah the one Minute Podcast it's
all in Rumble it's on my my website to
the creativitykit.com that's my online
course I put all my my old videos on
there
um but I'm gonna I'm gonna find a way to
re-release them it is a little bit of a
shame I think that was the biggest part
about what hit me the most about the
cancellation was the nine years of work
like almost a day my life's work
genuinely I moved on from that but
imagine putting your entire life into
one channel like you know hours of work
I dropped out of school I remember all
the all-nighters I was like driving
different places doing road trips you
know spending my last twenty dollars on
a micro on a wire for the microphone
just all the memories associated with
that and yes like of course I still have
backups of the videos but like look at
the dates in the comments section I got
I grew up on YouTube like a lot of
people you were talking about that
people have seen me go through puberty
on sneaker that's how long I've been
doing it since I was 14. and the fact
that they could just wipe that like that
in a second was like it's like they took
um it's like they took a part of me
I can't even I've been doing it a year
and I can't even imagine like I would
cry I would I would not be as positive
as you already there's nothing else to
do I'm not gonna I'm not gonna be a woke
victim like the only thing you could do
is keep it I'll cry for a day we're
still young I'm not no I just gotta keep
going yeah so what are your career goals
the next five years life goals career
goals make enough money to where I can
get out make enough money to where I can
start my own production company uh
continue to wake people up I want to
build a strong Network in the creativity
kit that's my I have a Discord uh server
where a lot of people are starting to
make money because making money online
is the future and so I want to have a
strong network of people around me I
want to continue adding value to that
course I would say in the next five
years is having a strong Network around
me so where the cancellation inevitably
whatever they want to take next it won't
hurt as bad because my reputation will
supersede any of the allegations I mean
I look at what's happening to Andrew and
Tristan freedom and you know it's
probably it's very likely that the same
thing could happen because we have
perhaps pretty much the exact same
message I said that as soon as they were
banned from Big Tech I said like am I in
my next and a lot of people like you
ain't [ __ ] nothing's gonna happen and
then boom white so the best thing to do
is prepare for the fact that the Matrix
and these people they don't want me to
be talking about this so I need to
prepare for the fact that they they shut
people like me out so next five years
become richer stronger better smarter
and continue to improve do you want ten
Suns twenty twenty twenty I think I want
five children but I mean I'm 24 we'll
see when I'm 30 or something like that
maybe I'll change my mind about that 10
son seems like a lot but then you can
have a whole volleyball team of your
kids yeah I think about that I always
say I want five boys and like they have
to be suit like I'm tall so they'll just
be like giants but you don't want any
daughters
um you're worried you can have a 304. no
no actually not really I
no like
hard being this tall
I feel like I'm on like the per like
okay if I got any taller it would be bad
okay like and I'm like if I had a six
two six three daughter that's so tall
like I have a different so that's why
you don't have a daughter because you're
gonna be tall and and I just don't like
women's sports that much so okay I'd
rather watch men's sport you don't watch
women's sports you can watch the WNBA no
of course not and I play I played
basketball last year too so I'm like I
played I played sports that was the only
thing I cared about until I was like 22.
does a part of you wish you were a guy
um no not really I see the stuff like oh
God I see the stuff that guys have to go
through like firsthand through the
channel and I'm like that would be a lot
harder
um sometimes I wish that I used to wish
that women's sports had money in it
because that I just loved women's sports
like I just loved playing just people
don't like watching it it's just not
entertaining and I'm not gonna be like
that's what they're trying to do to me
on the vice panel they're like oh are
you oppressed because women's sports
like doesn't make money yeah they try to
get that angle yeah and I'm like no
they're just not a center it doesn't
make money because no one watches it
yeah I don't even watch it so how am I
gonna be mad that no one else does what
team does Brittany grinder play for
I couldn't name one is there a Pelicans
team I don't know I thought Brittany
grinder was Brittany Renner for like
seven months everyone
and that's the thing like
I just refused to be a victim like I
just don't I don't know I just picked
something else
um
I think can we see about any more
questions I want to have daughters
though I don't just want to have a bunch
of sons I think it'd be good I think it
would balance out uh
I think it would be a good okay do you
want multiple wives like a lot of guys
in red pill want like multiple are you
gonna get multiple are you Pro monogamy
am I Pro okay I have weird views on
monogamy okay I feel like
I am from monogamy I'll just say yes
okay but I don't but I feel like it like
for the one percent five percent of guys
it kind of makes sense why they don't
want to
yeah ideally four wives sounds nice okay
we'll see if that's really attainable
you have to be extremely
successful rich and ready to handle that
I don't think mentally I'm ready for
four wives now no I'm not I'm not at
that point but that sounds ideally yeah
ideally I would I would say yes I do
okay I wasn't sure because I feel like
there's kind of a mix of that with the
red pill guys where like some end up
like getting married some even end up
getting married as weird as that is yeah
like uh Rollo Rollo tomasi is he married
right yeah but he's I feel like he's
different because I don't think he was
as aware when he got married you know I
mean
so you got red pill in his marriage I
think so and stayed in the marriage
well I mean if he likes his wife like
what is he gonna leave her he's already
married he's gonna leave his wife and
his daughter
whatever yeah I would love to be married
I'd love to be married eventually what
are your thoughts on Modern American
foreign policy
I Am pro Putin I think that we should
not involve ourselves in in foreign
affairs it's a proxy war we have no
business in Ukraine at all they're using
it that the same thing look what
happened with FDX they're using the
Ukraine war to funnel money to the
Democratic party ftxl it's just one
giant Global scam we should get out of
Ukraine uh we should let Putin take it
over he's completely Justified and and
wanting to invade wait oh my God what
yeah okay can you okay I need to know I
don't understand so I thought Russia was
like bad well that's that's part of the
programming but you don't really know
why no Putin's Justified so they're
they're putting a missiles and they're
putting uh weapons of mass destruction
in Ukraine right next to Russia
um and I think NATO wants to get Ukraine
involved and that they're trying to to
globalize the world it's all part of the
new world order so Putin wants to invade
he doesn't want you correct he doesn't
want missiles right next to his country
so he's invading he's saying no I'm
against NATO [ __ ] off and then America's
like but Ukraine is zelenski and he's a
good guy and we have not like why do we
care about Ukraine they've brainwashed
all of us Putin has completely Justified
on propun oh my God God am I blue pill
about foreign policy I think I am I
thought Russia was bad I don't even know
well I mean even if Russia was bad what
do we have business doing in Ukraine and
Russia that's that's their business we
look if we can learn from our mistakes
involving ourselves in Vietnam and Iraq
we should stop getting in wars that have
nothing to do with us and there's no
reason but America needs to constantly
be at War because there's so much money
that's generated you know the the arms
industry it's a business being at War
constantly funnels a lot of money they
also spend the money too like doesn't it
it's like a big percentage of our
nationality it's a giant scam like we
give 45 billion to zolenski and then
he's given handouts to different
politicians that money's not really
going to Ukraine oh
oh I see I got red pilled even further I
didn't even W poon
what are your thoughts on the Meg the
stallion Tory Lanez situation free Tory
Lanez uh Megan the sound was shot by
Kelsey Tory Lanez is an innocent man and
I think she's part of the I think she's
part of the psyop singer it's working
with She-Hulk I don't I don't believe
anything she says the Sia the psyop the
the belief system that we're supposed to
fall into the The Mirage of the reality
that's what the psyop is I I don't I
think it's all garbage she lied about
uh being in a sexual relationship with
Tory Lanez there's so many
inconsistencies she didn't go to the
police after for a month and then
eventually she did I I don't buy it at
all I think that Tory Lanez is innocent
and they tried to make him look like the
bad person I think it's very similar to
the Andrew taste situation Megan the
stallion is shaking hands with Hillary
Clinton that sets off red flags
oh my gosh do you think that was like
this like that was the Deep state that
trial
like maybe they own what if they own
Megan and they can't have her get in
trouble I do think they own Megan I mean
she's uh the perfect example of somebody
the leader of the feminist movement of
the leader of the girl boss movement uh
her name is the stallion male horse
Megan the male horse Megan the girl boss
Megan the [ __ ] feminist girl boss Queen
She twerks but she's also a
businesswoman she's pushing that girl
boss ideology to grow but they don't
actually want to do that girls want to
be feminine girls don't really want to
work as much as men did it this is not
their Lane but it's she is the image of
what they want girls to become and it's
making them unhappy I don't understand
that like why do people like Megan and
cardi B2
I mean cardi B like admitted to drugging
robbing men and looking at everybody's
outrage about Andrew Tate but she's like
okay yeah I drugged and robbed men and
everyone's so clapped he nobody cares
but when it's men nobody cares and it's
funny before I got like red pilled I
didn't realize how many like little
things in society are so anti-men and
you don't even notice it like the
example I always use is like Knocked Up
and that's just a random phrase right
but it puts the responsibility on the
men and not the women like if nothing is
ever our fault so like when you have
these delusional women that come in it's
because all of society nothing's ever
our fault and we don't get in trouble
for anything like Megan the stallion now
like literally blamed something on Tory
Lanez and he had to take the fall now
he's going to jail yeah yeah I mean
maybe he could appeal but as of now he's
facing something like 20 years
and I I met him like uh last month he
was a nice guy in his Studio he's very
friendly to me
um nice women nice people around him
nice dog I got to film in his Studio I
did the first podcast he was just
setting up a podcast studio in Miami
it's too bad um me and academic said
that he's just yeah great guy great guy
but do you think of the metoo movement
garbage I mean there's like two bad
people maybe Harvey Weinstein I
understand I mean if you're going to be
problematic about it movie career
but you got a movie career okay yes
power it's bad they don't actually want
to do it but
most girls get nothing out of it they
just get nut on their face and the guy's
broke and they never get to see him
again this guy you get a little bit of
old wine scene come but then you get an
entire movie career you know not that
bad the rest of them Louis CK bro what
did he do he's on the phone and he's
canceled like it's it's a lot of garbage
and a lot of people got light on I think
they expose a lot about how women lie
look at Javonte Davis right now he was
just arrested and then his baby mama
said oh I made the whole thing up what
is she getting in trouble I don't think
so and Javonte Davis he posted a picture
on his Instagram she was wiping [ __ ] on
his toothbrush it's disgusting like
women are told to act like children
while also being girl bosses because
they know they're not going to face any
accountability for their actions look in
in the comments right now we all know an
instance of a woman who lied about being
uh are awarded and we always move on oh
my God I have thoughts on this okay I
have thoughts before the show started
okay I really thought like nobody okay I
don't want to say nobody but I would say
I thought it was an exception that girls
would lie about that stuff like I
thought it was would be rare does that
make sense like I just thought oh it's
normalized oh my God because it would
have show after show after show
[Music]
they don't care someone are crazy I
swear God this show has changed me I
used to be a lot more patient you can't
be it once you see that it's it's
completely a clown World Pearl well
thank you so much for coming on today
this is fun thank you anything else you
want to tell the people tell them where
to find you rommel.com Nico and the
creativitykit.com I am launching uh my
new course February 1st so get ready for
that I want to build a strong community
and we're teaching you how to make money
online
yeah but rumble.com streaming every day
at 8pm I'm hoping that do you think
you're gonna post this full version or
you're going to post it in Clips I'm
thinking about
I I was gonna say I think we'll probably
put the full version on Rumble but like
Clips no I need to be on on the Main
Street platforms everyone already knows
me the full one
um what are they what do they take with
my channel that's the only thing you
could send maybe censor the parts where
that's what I was thinking I was like
I was like cut out like like the strike
worthy stuff the climate change election
yeah so I was gonna say like we'll
probably just cut like up in my head I
was thinking we have it cut and just say
this part's on Rumble you know what I'm
saying and then the next part keeps
going because I would like the full
version somewhere I mean like anybody
watching this uh one was going to take
over eventually but right now the
strategy for cancel people when you get
canceled is is to go and collaborate
with us I don't want to get canceled
it's Pearl it's it's inevitable I don't
want to say tell Susan to
or something that canceled with me no
don't
um but the the strategy is to stay on
mainstream platforms and do
collaborations with other people but at
the same time like you did a
collaboration with it's complicated
recently right
it's too he doesn't want to he's afraid
man like I told him that it's funny he
asked me if he should do it with you I
told him to do it so I'm really
surprised that he didn't put it up
because he asked me like should I do the
collab with sneaker I'm like I love
sneaker you got to put them on the
platform I know we had a great interview
I was there for like an hour and a half
yes he's a great interviewer and it
people are it was after my association
with yay they think I'm anti-semitic
stuff like that even people like on this
side can still risk their platforms but
that's why rumble's taking over yeah and
I'm sure we'll do more stuff I gotta get
you on a street interview or something
yeah I want to yeah I want to okay guys
um we'll probably put the little the
little pieces or the the bad part not
the bad parts the the strike worthy
Parts on Rumble maybe patreon we'll see
don't forget to like the video subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell and I'll talk to you next time
thank you bro